he's von Miller the Broncos linebacker
it seems to be a Super Bowl tradition
well except when he's playing in the
Super Bowl but good see Vaughn how are
you I'm doing pretty good you and
Brittany had another emotional moment
there of course this bonding with the
Broncos win Super Bowl you reached out
to him and one of the great gestures
ever ever to say fritzy would you like
to be on the Super Bowl parade float I
know but the way you present it it's
like I'm blowing off my team that I've
been rooting for since 1977
the pointers try to bring out what you
did Vaughn invited them but I have a
very close bond with my son who has
watched me over to scream and yell
deceiving regale go crazy and the
thoughts of going to the game and not
being having my son by my side and I
appreciated that you offer for the
ticket in the parade and all that it was
great and thanks for the Broncos won
Super Bowl 50 MB done right with their
head princey could I couldn't I wouldn't
have had a good time bye :
my son is just a crazy a fan is I
probably work now you should see how he
acts you know 14:23 left in the first
quarter
if Denver doesn't do something great
he's screaming at the TV literally I was
incomplete why did you throw it so why
the song a two-yard at some third name
up on it's good to have you back but it
was a hollow victory because Richie
wasn't there on the Super Bowl parade
float is that what you said it was a
little bit of a disappointment let Mel
down after beating Carolina I mean it
was but you know getting the explanation
from you know Fritzi today I got respect
yeah I respect that 100% we're going to
be bet so no cry no do not have another
chance to make it a threesome did you
make fans cry when you guys won like
Bronco fans tears of joy did you run
into people who it was that emotional to
them I mean it was them the emotions
were crazy you got guys crying you got
the feelings that you get from being in
the Super Bowl is you can't really
explain it it's good what is the party
like after the Super Bowl
um it's great it's great any less about
you know three four months so little
kids yes a really long it's a really
really long party but after the after
the
so you just you win it's you get the
trophy and then you go doing a hotel
ballroom I didn't end up getting back to
the hotel till about 2:30 in the morning
too
so I just had enough time to get out and
go out to a club where all my teammates
was at and get back I don't really get
any sleep
you know the night in school go what is
that reaction like though once you
realize you're gonna win a Super Bowl I
don't know what point of the game I
don't know if it was when you had a you
know strip sack or at what point did you
say I'm a Super Bowl champ oh I was
going to sideline after the second strip
sack in the offense work they won the
ball and run at the time and they punted
the ball back to Cam Newton and it was
only like two minutes left when we were
up by 10 points that's worth I still
kind of feel like you know the Caroline
was counting on the pedals gonna work
some magic and you know scored touchdown
you get all sidekick you know there was
still a possibility but um the emotion
starts to ease a little bit when we got
that second strip set how many times
should be watched that Super Bowl oh I
watched it about three or four times
there's one yeah and what are you
looking for when you watch them oh I'm
just looking at the energy that we had
as a team you can see the conference
that we had as a team from you know 18
all the way down to you know the guys on
the sidewalk you know we came into the
game we felt like we had a huge chance
to win that game and after we start
making a few plays the confidence got
the rolling in boom Super Bowl 50 champ
do you say anything to Cam Newton any
time you hit it and I was uh you know I
was just so worried about getting with
my teammates and celebrating with my
teammates every single time we made a
play I'm I just wanted to be around my
guys but we're watching to play right
now so you're not saying anything to cam
it all when you pop it I just think I
didn't say anything the whole game
nothing yeah wow I've never really I'm
not really a big know social guy on the
field I really don't I really don't do a
lot of talking I'm I'm so busy thinking
about the next play and the play that we
have called it you know I really don't
do a lot of talk with any quarterbacks
talk um Phillip Rivers oh yes in the
rivers arm but you had some great things
to say about Phillip Rivers recently
like it's now fritzy can't stand Phillip
find Eliza crying and complaining for
the refs everything's like going against
in that's accepted but rob was the
better that's understandable he is a
great quarterback if you look at some of
the teams that he's had and some of the
stuff that he was able to do with those
teams you know it's incredible honestly
he's Von Miller joining us on behalf of
Old Spice so what are you doing with old
spy are you working with a Travis Kelce
two on this Travis Kelce came by and
talked to about old spy he's a wild man
yeah Travis you know what he's a he's a
funny dude he's like all bro spending
time with Travis at the Pro Bowl like
he's one of the all-time you know great
guys by the national football he has the
personality is the swag you know he has
a TV show for the ladies and stash you
know he's definitely a superstar my book
I like been around tracks what are you
doing with Old Spice I'm here well twice
today promoting the new hydro wash it
has a lasting hydration expect and a
lasting scent just like all those Spice
products noise in all 32 locker rooms so
it was good enough for the big ugly's in
the locker room it's a you know good
enough for everybody else you ever worn
cologne before again before game yeah I
usually like to you know shower before I
go out and get all of that but but you
don't do cologne no cologne guys no you
ever smelled cologne in the pond you
know I haven't smoked alone but I have I
have been in apollomon the smell is just
been so terrible we've made two Oakland
Raiders and like the ultimate Raiders
I'm not gonna name any names but you
know it's like the Oakland Raiders in
there they have one of the biggest
offensive linemen really the best sick
first their second best arguably the
best for the Cowboys line International
Football League again you know we were
getting pushed around a lot that game I
ended up on the bottom of Paulo you know
a couple of times and it was bad those
guys could use him all in class you guys
interested in Tony Romo
oh my do you ever want your team to be
interested in Tony room I want I want
mr. Elway just to continue the magic
that he's done why he's been with the
Denver Broncos I miss Elway season he
always comes back and he always does
willing to offseason everything that
he's supposed to do for a team he's
gotten a pluses on that so I'm just
looking for a great offseason for my
front office from mr. Elway and lock and
load and get back look at you look at
you being a veteran there
veteran yeah responded not given any but
you know handling material I mean he's I
mean he's a man if Tony Romo's of guys
in here do it it's not like he'd know he
understands exactly what our team needs
and he's going he's gonna put us in
great situation to win he's done it
every single year we've been in national
budget how many times you played against
free Tom Brady mr. another Brady not
right I didn't either here I didn't hear
you but yeah I played against um Tom
quite a few times I think every single
time of the National Football do and
what do you what are your thoughts
wait what are you gonna tell your
grandkids about face and Brady I mean
he's great I mean I never I've never
played against Peyton so you know
playing against you know Tom Brady he's
great I like to think that Peyton
Manning is to go out I've seen them I've
been around them but Tom Brady is it's
arguably you know the goat as well you
he's great
got a couple of sacks on him okay who
would you who have you not gotten that
you want I haven't got um me back
Prescott uh-huh nah he's only a rookie
yeah are you going Ricky um Russell
Wilson Eli Manning I got wrong and I
mean it's a few quarterbacks that I
haven't been able you know to to toggle
if there's anybody all-time that you
just you'd like one of those shots where
it's just you and the back of their
jersey probably Ryan sending here fine
we played all on the college level you
know who's like college ball together so
the Aggie connection there yeah
never got to hit him in practice we
played them play the Dolphins one time
you know he [ __ ] me a couple time you
know I would like to walk out on her you
know doing a segment for him you know
what do you have over there Paulie
Vaughn said they'd never gotten dak
Prescott yet nope that's too bad too bad
that he hasn't gotten dak Prescott yet
this would fit McLovin wouldn't it lovin
would you put it on let Don Miller here
would you do this
I don't know act when you looking at him
his elbow is bigger than my whole arm
yeah yeah I'll do it now now I would
like bond to read his draft profile here
now we we of course took out all the
positives here Vaughn and will you dream
you read your draft profile that hadn't
Simon see now this is coming out of
college what I said about you this is by
NFL scouts now we edited out the
positive just so you know yeah it is far
more lon it means we have to hit so here
is Von Miller with his draft profile
coming out of Texas A&M I'm going to
start young the first weaknesses does
not have a thick lower half that's
correct
I mean like I guess got a little
personal there but okay
female exercise female exercise to
consistently anchor the run I mean I
like to think I'm you're okay again
surround you okay it gets through all
right take support angles at times the
rest support I mean I just didn't have
many songs we don't coming on alright
lacks the experience in man coverage and
will not be able to cover more athletic
tight ends I mean I mean somebody you
know is that fair it's rarely notice
where I come out of college you know you
got to find stuff you know that guys
need to improve it and this is you know
some of the stuff that I had trouble
with some other colors very small frame
gets overwhelmed at point of attack week
versus the row hand use could improve
knees to a strip those aren't terrible
no I mean how did you make it the NFL
after all these negatives they're gone
I mean I guess I just had guys that that
saw you know the positive stuff in me I
saw the you know the good stuff that I
could do or contribute Richard Richard
Smith for the Atlanta Falcons the
defensive coordinator for last Mountain
you know I guess he saw something you
know in me that everybody else didn't
see I came in and I played Sam
linebacker right away man cover zone
athletic tight ends right away I was
able to play the run right away so he
did a great he did an incredible job
coaching me up getting me ready good do
you have a chip on your shoulder I do I
do it is actually standing on that hill
wait wait you have a tattoo this is chip
I have a tattoo this is chill on my
shirt I do have a chip on my way let me
roll up your sleeve let me let me see if
we can please self - yeah it's going a
long way like that he does have a
legitimate chip on his shoulder
dad is awesome here alright before we
let you go you're joining us on behalf
of Old Spice here and you can go to Old
Spice YouTube page to learn more about
the new implement by the way you're
doing great with the commercials on
making they're really good you got you
you got a future and doing that is very
very entertaining they're appreciate
McLovin would you put on the dak
Prescott Jersey and let Vaughn paulie's
got a block just so you know how great
Holly is gonna block bond I would have
fritzy but he won't do that he'll let
you sack McLovin no question yeah all
right so Vaughn is going to pop McLovin
I'll mention once again bond is joining
us on behalf of Old Spice
hardest-working collection NFL campaign
and the latest product innovation new
hydro wash body wash learn more the
Hydra watch this lasting scent and the
ultra ultra superior hydration by
watching buns new infomercial an Old
Spice YouTube page one of the great sack
men in the NFL and a future Hall of
Famer and the MVP of last year's Super
Bowl von Miller and if you are just
listening to the program hopefully you
can hear McLovin cry as bong hits him
okay
yeah yeah yep yeah well done thank you
Vaughn the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
[Music]